what did you think about um
the steve jobs presentation of the the
iphone
the the sort of the first iphone
you know phone uh internet communicator
and the ipod in your pocket yeah they're
going to sort of present
you're
announcing three new products
kind of thing and then saying that it's
all in one just this is a good example
one of the sort of
historic
presentations of a product uh
clearly there's like some showmanship
that works some reason it works right it
doesn't always work it often doesn't
work but it did in in this case it often
did for steve what like how did that
feel
um
what part of the actually
uh
the design process
was that presentation you know what i
mean like from the early because you
said for sure so consider the why the
press release at the very exactly
steve was doing that the entire time he
was working on that story from day one
yeah he was pitching us this this this
and then this and and then he would look
at our faces because you wouldn't most
people wouldn't at least if you're
working for him wouldn't tell him what
you really thought of what he was saying
but he would look at your faces yeah and
then he would talk to a few real trusted
confidence outside of the
uh outside of the organization
and see what they thought right and they
could give him feedback on it and they
could really challenge him but they
could he would also look at their faces
and go
and so when you see that
then he would modulate it and change it
slightly and change so he was working
during all of that time on the story and
the storytelling
right and the whys
while we're working on that and helping
us refine it just like the switch from
plastic to glass right
all the time working on that so when he
comes out on stage he does something
that every marketer is told not to do
say these three things are now combined
in one
that is like the
that they say that that is the laziest
form of storytelling possible for
marketing
yeah right but it was the best one
because it was all those panes it was
like i want my ipod but i want my
communications and i want my internet
browsing because i want it on the go so
i can look up things because it was
information
and when you were on the road you had a
laptop you had an ipod and you had a
phone that and you had to carry all of
these things with you at once
now we're going to solve that pain
for you and put it all together so he
was just showing you the pain and
beating that virus of doubt and going
it's now in this one magical thing
and he could come up and masterfully
tell that story because he told it
almost every day
to all of these people inside very
quietly and then it was just
right it was like a you know a tony
award-winning play that had been worked
on for 10 years but also the human came
through the timing it was all that it
was yeah and of course he was dramatic
at certain points and he would raise his
voice and
a wry smile or whatever it was right
all those touches he was an actor as
well as a storyteller yeah and that but
but it was the truth
right
the truth came through it was a
non-fiction story and then he added
those personal flourishes on top of it
for dramatic effect
it's amazing
you